arena first of all congratulations
smooth sailing it seemed like but what
was that wild opening tell us about that
yeah yeah
i guess you couldn't have guessed i was
going to go for this sicilian today
because i've never played it before in
my life
um yeah you know that was some
um an idea i had for this game you know
it's funny because the opening is very
sharp but of course there's a chance
that it could go into something kind of
tame right and that's what happened
and you know yeah it's a bit of a
calculated guess right like if you feel
like your opponent's not super prepared
for these crazy lines certainly she
couldn't have expected that for me um
you know that gives you a little bit of
room right to play something very crazy
so you might think um it's not always
like playing the most boring opening is
the way to get the results you need uh
sometimes you can go through something
really crazy and still it works out
actually well like that so that's how it
happened in this game and it felt like
you were just very well prepared up to
this point were you concerned at all
about this move knight to d6 that yasser
is pointing up yeah well that's the main
move so of course this is still theory
oh yeah oh yeah i mean knight d6 is the
main move right
um and
bishop b7
so yeah that this this position is
literally just the beginning of like you
know there there's theory here that goes
like for 30 moves right so
um yeah of course that was a possibility
um but she took an f6 yeah went for
queen d4 it's like a solid looking move
but of course black has no real problems
in this end game i don't know if i could
have been even more ambitious like
um
i'm not sure where like my move seems
pretty normal to me a bishop e7 is
definitely
kind of normal because otherwise white
might play c5 at some point your bishop
might get stuck
um king f2 i castled i realized like i
actually kind of wanted to keep the
queens on the board in this position but
i don't know if i should spend a tempo
moving away the queen and white could
try to play c5 so we got into this
position and uh
d5
yeah she she did play something
interesting here which was this move
rook f1 now i didn't see that one coming
and i thought that was quite a nice move
um you know with the idea of hiding the
king on g1 so that e5 it neutralizes one
of my main ideas
and then i was like okay i should be a
little bit careful here right because
i still have you know the bishop on b7
that's not so great and uh she has the
queen side majority so you have to play
with a bit of care
so i got this trade and
um the one last interesting moment was
here like where i went rook c2
and she you know she surprised me a bit
yeah she went for rook a4 um i guess
yeah and brook fca so i realized i could
play for more you know no stepping back
with rook c5 that had been the point and
yeah after rook a5 i can go rook d2
try to get my rook to the second and of
course black is not risking anything
there only white
so i was exp at g3 and
um she kind of like you know didn't go
for the rook trade with rook f1
so
probably the game could have ended if
she just would have
you know done something like that
um obviously i can't really win just a
single rook end game
and but when she decided not to do it i
was like okay well white's trying to win
but they're trying to win a position
where they're not better and they have a
lot less time so
uh that's fine
and eventually though
[Music]
yeah i mean i do feel like uh black
i would i'm happier playing black here
but i didn't see like anything very
clear and um you know i just i needed
this result to get on to the next round
and that was that was enough
perfect thank you irina how do you feel
about your uh performance up to this
point from a decision-making point of
view from a choice of opening point of
view how do you feel yeah i feel pretty
good my opening choices i think for this
match have worked out really well
um i you know obviously when that works
out really well you also tend to play
better right because you know not facing
as many problems
um so i feel like pretty good time
management was good i mean playing
pretty easily keeping my energy and that
i think that's really the most important
thing for this tournament is like you
actually don't want to play too many
crazy games spending hours at the board
because you have so many matches right
so the more energy that you can conserve
the better thank you irina and we'll see
you tomorrow yeah see you tomorrow guys
good luck arena and we do go back to